[Música]
en otros temas la lesión de ligamento
cruzado anterior es de una a tres veces
superior en futbolistas mujeres que en
sus colegas hombres solo en los últimos
meses al menos 11 jugadoras
profesionales han caído incapacitadas
por este daño un estudio que fue
realizado por el Instituto
señaló que al menos una en cada cienes
futbolistas que están en activo lo
sufren a lo largo de su carrera y por
qué sucede esto Pues nos lo va a contar
la doctora Alejandra jimce quien es
médica deportóloga de la comisión es
directiva de la asociación Argentina de
médicos del deporte y del tribunal
Nacional de sanciones antidopaje además
de directora médica en diversas
organizaciones también está en el
estudio de France 24 Juan pupiales para
participar de esta entrevista Juan es
doctora Muchísimas gracias
cómo le va Muchas gracias por la
invitación y feliz de estar con ustedes
desde acá Igualmente doctora vamos a
empezar hablando de esta investigación
del doctor Ramón cugat que cita factores
anatómicos mecánicos y hormonales
quisiera preguntarle Cuáles son Estos
factores
a ver los anatómicos es una cosa
intrínseca que tenemos las mujeres donde
las caderas son mucho más anchas que los
hombres Gracias por eso podemos procrear
y las rodillas están en un ángulo mucho
menor entonces esa tensión que soporta
el ligamento cruzado es el que termina
haciendo que tengamos más riesgo de
ruptura de cruzado en este tipo de
deportes de contacto
doctora qué tiene Qué relación tiene que
ver también la formación que tienen las
mujeres en comparación con los hombres
estamos en un momento de explosión del
fútbol femenino en donde cada vez hay
más países que buscan que sea
profesional pero en general los
futbolistas hombres comienzan su carrera
atlética por decirlo así mucho más
jóvenes que las mujeres Cuál es el
impacto de esto en esta que pueda tener
en esta lesión de ligamento cruzado
anterior
exactamente Juan eso es lo que pasa
nosotras recién estamos lo digo nosotros
Porque me encanta este deporte estamos
empezando a tener cada vez más y muy
abrupta participación en fútbol que es
algo muy muy bueno y Súper provechoso lo
que tienes que no salteamos tal vez lo
que se llama la fase sensible de esta
capacidad o habilidad básica como es la
coordinación la velocidad todo lo que
uno aprende es en la infancia esa
capacidad de la fase sensible del
aprendizaje de ciertas cosas a nivel
neurológico Sí más allá que lo muscular
se aprende en las primeras fases de la
infancia de los seis a los diez años
entonces como no jugábamos al fútbol por
lo menos yo a los diez y a los seis años
claramente me salte ese aprendizaje y lo
fuimos las mujeres aprendiendo cada vez
más adelante en la edad cuando se
empieza y espero que las nuevas
generaciones empiecen jugar al fútbol y
a deportes de contacto y y y de equipo
mucho más temprano en la edad y Y eso es
re importante como decimos en Argentina
propiciar a las mujeres a empezar juegos
de equipo tempranamente hace que de
adulto estas cosas No ocurran doctora
pero es que además las mujeres tenemos
una composición diferente en nuestros
ligamentos que tienden a ser más laxos y
y hay otra cosa que señala este estudio
que nos llama mucho la atención y es
como las zapatillas deportivas no están
diseñadas para nuestro pie nosotras no
fuimos los modelos para crear estos
zapatos especiales
exactamente Ángela en cuanto al tema
de la importancia de las hormonas como
afectan los ligamentos eso se ve no solo
en el ligamento cruzado anterior sino en
todos los ligamentos de nuestro cuerpo
donde en la fase ovulatoria quiere decir
en el momento que estamos ovulando hay
un pico de una hormona que se llama lh
que es la que necesitamos para que
empiece justamente la mujer a ovular y
en ese momento hay mucho mucha cantidad
de lh estrógenos y termina siendo quien
termina haciendo un poco más laxo los
ligamentos en esa fase hay algunos
estudios que muestran también que
posterior a esa fase
se secreta como se dice las hormonas se
libera una hormona que es la relaxina
tipo dos y termina siendo también unos
ligamentos mucho mucho más laxos esa
hiperlaxitólica que tienen las mujeres
hace que cuando nos enfrentamos a un
cambio de dirección abrupto a poner los
botines en una grama muy alta
un choque desde la de la rodilla desde
lateral por ejemplo cuando uno va a
defender una pelota y el otro la va a
atacar termina pasando que podría llegar
a romperse mucho más frecuente que un
hombre que no tiene todas estas hormonas
dando vuelta con lo cual el ciclo
menstrual es muy muy importante tomarlo
como base para el entrenamiento para ver
en qué momentos se aumenta la intensidad
o no Para cuándo se pone una jugadora y
no otra jugadora o sea hay que empezar a
usar el ciclo menstrual como parte de la
programación de los entrenamientos y de
los partidos
doctora son mujeres están jugando hoy en
día con unas botas que se hicieron para
los hombres y se adaptaron para las
mujeres Qué impacto tiene también esto a
la hora de las lesiones y otra pregunta
hay hoy en día planes o ya tenemos botas
diseñadas específicamente para las
mujeres
bueno a ver ahí en cuanto a toda la
investigación científica que existe en
deporte un 30% solamente están en las
mujeres y estos en los últimos 15 a 20
años quiere decir que recién se está
investigando mujeres como es la
biomecánica Cómo es la pisada qué
requerimientos Qué necesidades tenemos
no solo en esto y más imagínense que en
todos los deportes en baloncesto que es
enorme la ruptura de ligamento cruzado
anterior con lo cual termina pasando que
faltan años de investigación esa es la
realidad es verdad solamente estamos
usando incluso todo el equipamiento no
solo los botines todo el equipamiento
deportivo se está usando Recién ahora se
está empezando a investigar y el proceso
de investigación donde vamos a ver cuál
es la biomecánica que necesita y que
botín vamos a necesitar este las mujeres
usar Así que faltan años de
investigación Pues hay otros deportes el
running por ejemplo que tiene mucho más
investigación en esto en la mujer pero
bueno el fútbol recién empezamos doctora
como como una experta y además como una
fanática del deporte Pues usted sabe que
este este esta rotura implica muchísimo
tiempo de baja un tratamiento importante
y además pues que no siempre está al
alcance de las jugadoras Simplemente
porque hay una brecha laboral
impresionante todavía alrededor del
mundo Qué necesitan las jugadoras de
parte de sus directivas y de sus torneos
para garantizar que tengan no solo un
tratamiento adecuado sino una prevención
adecuada y y un cuidado en general para
su carrera deportiva
sí es como lo decís termina pasando que
una lesión de cruzado puede estar con el
tratamiento perfecto Sí Entre cuatro y
seis meses y después viene la vuelta al
campo entonces lo que es reinserción con
entrenamientos diferenciados Entonces es
realmente largo la va a dejar media
temporada o incluso una temporada fuera
o se van a saltear una pretemporada si
están en proceso de recuperación post
quirúrgica de un ligamento cruzante por
lo tanto Qué necesitamos Y si la
pregunta es esta es paciencia progresión
necesitamos cobertura médica hay muy
pocas mujeres
médicas trabajando en fútbol todavía es
algo que recién se está empezando a
hacer hay muy pocas fisiólogas hay muy
pocas este kinesiólogas y la verdad es
que necesitamos empezar a darle al
fútbol femenino todas las
características
de un fútbol que hoy por hoy es
profesional Pero bueno la
profesionalidad la profesionalización
lleva tiempo lleva tiempo y Lleva dinero
también por supuesto doctora me gustaría
profundizar en la lesión como tal es una
lesión que se dice acaba con la carrera
de futbolistas y matizar que esta lesión
es lo que está marcando precisamente el
mundial femenino que tendremos ahora en
julio con primera vez con 32 selecciones
de fincas carino de Francia la última de
ellas en ser afectado Elías williamson
de Inglaterra la capitana de Inglaterra
Alexia de España se lesionó en junio del
año pasado apenas va a jugar un partido
entero espera hacerlo en este mundial
porque esta lesión es tan difícil tan
dura y con una recuperación que puede
ser tan extensa
bueno la primera causa es que el
ligamento es quien le da entre otras
estructuras pero es muy muy fundamental
la estabilidad esa rodilla y para colmo
la rodilla Argentina la rodilla digamos
femenina digo Argentina porque
en Argentina tenemos mucha incidencia de
cruzado anterior roto femeninas también
y termina pasando que esas rodillas
femeninas termina teniendo una
dependencia de estabilidad en ese
cruzado mucho mayor por este ángulo
Q que les contaba al principio que es
ese ancho de caderas mayor que las
rodillas y tiene una tensión enorme
sumado a eso el tendón digamos el
ligamento es más angosto la donde se
inserta para hablar un poquito más de la
anatomía es como más angosta esa fosita
donde se va a insertar y genera un
tendón un poquito más débil que el del
hombre entonces en proporción Sí
entonces tiene más tensión y encima
tiene menos sostén quiere decir que
rotos te ligamento la rodilla
pierde estabilidad y hasta que eso no
está reparado el 100% y son los tiempos
que el hueso tarda en osificarse y es el
tiempo en que el músculo tarda en volver
y hipertrofiarte absolutamente
ya nos quedamos en tiempo pero muchas
gracias a usted Por hablarnos de lo que
es la ciencia del deporte y la anatomía
de los deportistas gracias a usted Juan
también y que tenga un feliz día doctora
Pues bien Juana creo que llegamos Ya el
momento de hacer una pequeña pausa más
tarde vuelvo con usted para más deportes
y con nuestros televidentes para más
titulares
[Música]